what writing failure has taught you the
most
it's funny i i i the first novel i wrote
was terrible
uh but i think
you have to write it to learn how to
write a novel it's like you have to
write a screenplay to learn how to write
a screenplay
um
so you just have to fail
uh
at the same time you kind of gotta as
you come to your first novel you know
you have to think oh it's gonna be
published it's to be great oh everyone's
going to love it i'm a novelist just
like
um
and then you're just like you know
a year or two in and you're like
yeah i can't do anything with this
i got nothing but you you've put in the
time and you kind of get the idea of
what needs to be done in order to you
know
write to write a novel so
did you think it was bad or did other
people say it uh no i thought it was bad
and i
it was bad
it was it was all over the place
um
yeah i was
so what was it about
uh it was uh it was about a marriage
that was breaking up
and uh
yeah
it's funny because it was like
night i wrote it like nine years before
my marriage broke up so maybe i was for
just foretelling my future
but uh
yeah it's you know
i was young and precious i think i think
if i'm precious with my work that's when
there's a problem i can't be precious
um
do you think you cared about the novel
too much
i know i think i cared about the the the
label of me as a novelist too much i
think i was a little too hyped on that
um
there's there's a beauty to there's a
beauty to um
what's interesting is once like once i
got published
and then your book comes out
there's a whole oh is that all there is
that's you know that peggy lee song is
that all there is to book publishing
except just different words but um
but it that's
that's the greatest club to be in
because
then you talk to other writers and
you're just like oh hey yeah yeah how's
your book
you know when it's out and and that's
that's usually the thing it's
it's uh
they could be or they could be excited
it's on the bestseller list but
they got 12 interviews to do that day
and it's like so there's still that
oh okay i gotta get you know i
i gotta get in this mindset of actually
caring about a book that i finished a
year ago
and um you know
it's uh it's bougie problems i guess
do you think people feel the same once
their film comes out
or that's different
um
the
uh when
when a jesus jerk came out
um
so well i got to see the rough cut and
then when i when then when i saw it at
the first film festival was at
i didn't i didn't know what the final
cut was gonna be
so
when i so when i was there
uh it was fun to watch but then i was
realizing that i was trying i was i was
gauging the audience i was i was
listening to the audience more than i
was watching the movie
um because i wanted to make sure the
jokes were landing and i wanted to make
sure that when there was supposed to be
silence there was silence
and um
so that's how that worked and then i saw
it one more time at another festival
and uh and i did the same thing
and i was just like all right
what's what jokes what jokes are landing
what's working what's not working and it
was kind of consistent i was like
oh okay you know i'm just a screenwriter
i'm not the director but
when he you know he was there too and
then uh
and then after that i
uh there was another screening and i
just stayed for the first act
i was waiting for one punchline
to see if the audience got it and then
they all got it and then i left and came
back later to do q a
um i don't know if i've ever seen it
again in its entirety
and
it's uh
it's a weird relationship because
i you know
i see the film and i see where i go oh i
was right off camera to the left oh
that's the day that
you know that associate producer got in
a fight with the unit production manager
oh you know that's that's the day that i
was hiding behind the truck out of to
make sure i was out of frame but i can
see that it's so
uh my relationship to it is
it's um
it's it's it's almost incestuous it's
almost too much to see um
and
it's uh you know
very happy with it but it's uh
it's a little disconcerting i guess so
again and i got to see it
in production so seeing it in production
is a very different experience and a
very lovely experience i think that was
my favorite part of the experience is to
see
the different takes and the
different choices the actors were making
and
you know i'm looking at eric and going
oh my god they're making me look good
and you'd be like we're making both of
us look good
so
yeah if the audience hadn't laughed at
that one
punch line
what would have happened
i probably would have been we've totally
failed utter failure
yeah
um
those yeah i had definite punchlines in
mind
and a lot of them are lead actors sasha
had to uh deliver and um
and he did great and uh
yeah it was you know it worked
so sure but sometimes you know audiences
don't you we've all been in a film where
we're the only ones laughing and we're
like why why am i the only one that's
laughing here yeah yeah that's on that
example i mean i
but at the same time that movie was
everything to me because that movie was
about me
that movie was my life um and that book
was my life so it was
the you know it was uh
i wasn't sure if i should write it as a
memoir i mean i was writing it as a
novel to test it out as a novel and i
wasn't sure if i should pull out some of
the
fictitious things to make it a memoir
when it was still in book form but it
read
better as a novel to me and it read
better with
more uh
more leniency into facts of
the world up now i i was a journal i was
a journalist i took a journalistic
approach
to the world of the jehovah's witnesses
so i made sure everything was absolutely
factual
to the to the nth degree
across the board so i actually had to do
a lot of research on that but
that movie was that movie was me growing
that movie was all me and so that movie
was the most that will be the most
important movie
probably of my career
because that's the story i needed to
tell and i needed to tell it that way
and not in the woe is me oh my god i
grew up in a restrictive religion no i
don't want i didn't want that i wanted
the levity of you know
there's of the okay and why people are
there and i i wanted i wanted more i
didn't want a definitive
answer and um
to a lot of to a lot of uh you know
those ex-jehovah's witnesses out there
who do not like the movie because i did
because i portrayed the jehovah's wit i
don't say anything bad about the
jehovah's witnesses and i'm like that's
on purpose because this is a
just a character study and it's
essentially me so
how does that character differ from
johnny swede
yeah yeah yeah that's the fictional
character i should have clung on to um
so
uh the character's name is gabe and uh
he's he's he's just earnest he's trying
to just find his truth and he's trying
to live in it and he's trying to stay a
jehovah's witness
and that's kind of what i did i was
trying to find my way to stay in
because i believed it
through my soul so
but i also wanted to
feel okay around people who weren't
jehovah's witnesses
and i also just wanted love
um so a lot of that is just the yearning
for um
for someone to be in love with
and you know me as a you know i know the
backstory of me because when i was six
years old i was engaged to pamela
uh because i asked her to marry me and
she said yes you know i just i was very
i was very romantic
um
and just had this yearning for family
and that's how i saw my way out of
feeling bad if
it's like oh when i have a wife then
i'll feel better as a jehovah's witness
and so
uh you know the jesus jerk doesn't go
that far into it jesus jerk is
kind of
ten years of my life smashed into a
six months so
but johnny swayed he
forgive me i'm gonna now i'm gonna go
watch the movie because now you have me
intrigued i wanna see and you know who
doesn't want to see a brad pitt movie so
what would um what about that character
do you wish could have been you
um i don't know if i wish he could have
been me i think i just related to him
because he's kind of dumb
but he's earnest
so there's just like he's making
mistakes left and right
and
the
you know not that time in my life
it was pretty tumultuous because that
was around the same time that my friend
had died and
i was um
i think i was just looking for something
and i think
the character like johnny suede was
trying to just fit into something
and he just he just wanted he really
just wanted a girlfriend
and
he was he just and he wasn't mature
enough to understand when
the right girl was right in front of him
that
it was right and uh
and i just it yeah so that all kind of
made sense to me